it's time for Friday Follies joining me
now the delightful the hilarious Kennedy
host of Kennedy Saves the World on Fox
News podcast when do you start the
saving that's what I'd like to know you
know I have to do it every single day
Raymond every week it's a big job I feel
like Atlas I cannot shrug I've got the
world on my shoulders I have to save it
okay as you know we regularly offer tips
for air travel on the show tonight I
want your rules okay a drunken passenger
refused to leave the plane
she caused a delay and a near Riot watch
me what I did doesn't matter then I'm
not going you're keeping up everybody
please leave so we can go on put it off
everybody
should be ashamed of yourself now
everybody's gonna
suffering
I love that I feel like that's her dad
she's lying with her and he's like you
should be ashamed you should be ashamed
of yourself and you know she's heard
that just chirping in her ear her entire
life everyone's got to be special
everyone's gotta cause the delay
everyone's gotta be a booze bag it's so
annoying it's like you don't know where
these people are going you don't know
where they're coming from Kennedy three
cops it took to remove her why would you
would think the public shame and the cat
calls would be enough you know the
heckling would have driven her there is
no shame just go to San Francisco walk
around New York there's no shame
what am I thinking but here's my rule
what's your rule if you delay a Plane by
having law enforcement come on and
detain you you have to pay not only for
everyone's drinks they at least have a
chance to get as soused as you you have
to pay for everyone's flight okay that's
the rule all right we'll hold them to it
now Kennedy like Kamala or Kamala we
have a new political star who changes
their preferred name pronunciation who
is it Ron DeSantis or is it DeSantis
Ron desantis.com go to rondisantis.com
people go uh to Ron desantis.com and
make a contribution I'm Ron DeSantis and
I'm running for president you say
DeSantis I say tomorrow
where do we go from here
um here's here's why he's doing that
because when you say DeSantis people
think it's dis or d-a-s so they're going
to misspell the URL he's not going to
get the money he knows he needs to think
that's why he's punching that ears D
santis not because he's trying to prove
a point or change a pronunciation he
just wants people to give give I can't
blame the guy that is something I had
not thought of but I think the media I
know thank you for again saving my world
uh now you got to move over to Jesse
water see what you can do there I think
the media may need a style guide into
Santa's pronunciation the watch he
called himself D santis his entire life
and then the last year he call himself
duh saddest it's kinda kinda strange
we'll call him whatever he wants to be
called which is it I feel like when I'm
saying D santis I feel like I'm making
fun of him no maybe he doesn't like the
duh because it sounds like you're saying
duh what's your name see I I worry there
are too many pronunciations now I mean
you've got Trump now who's entered de
sanctimonious and Des sancta to Sanctus
to Sanctus he also called him Rob
several times after the the Twitter
rollout what is that Rob and Stacy D
santis well DeSantis or does Santos did
settle it I think
there's been some confusion over your
last name and the pronunciation and I'm
just wondering to correct the record
what is it oh that's ridiculous these
stupid things listen the way to
pronounce my last name winner
oh winner winner chicken
well does that work come on I think he
should re he needs to find one
pronunciation and stick to it for
everybody but I think your explanation
might be the win the actual that's
that's what he's doing yeah Kennedy this
may be the most distressing headline of
the night gen Z is having a sex
recession a match.com study found 81
percent of young men said sex was less a
priority post-pandemic some blame social
media and porn but if gen Z is suffering
the 80 year olds are not
a baby yeah you got a new baby yes
how is fatherhood at this moment this
stage in age
listen Al Pacino just had a baby I was
told yesterday morning and he's a few
years older than me God bless him it is
so weird that you guys are both you and
patina are both having babies right now
yeah yeah
Kennedy what can gen Z learn from these
elders
uh that if you're you're packing Viagra
you'll keep packing babies well done
gents well but at least at least I'm
proud of them but at least they're in
the marketplace which is more than I can
say for the porn basement dwellers I
mean no that's that's a bummer and it's
it's really a bummer for young women
because if dudes like
I don't feel like it I want to talk
about anything don't look at me it's
like really like you know these two
walking cucumbers are impregnating women
in their 20s willy-nilly and guys in
their toys
[Music]
come on the pandemic's over it's very
man up Kennedy that's a beautiful way to
end the weekend and you were in
Davenport Iowa at the Adler Theater
tomorrow with Jimmy phela I wish I could
get a ticket laughs and Liberty tour
there it is there it is so go see them
it's going to be fantastic I can't wait
to see it myself Kennedy thank you have
a great weekend hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe live to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else